all right you can label this the coolest
day of the week for me you can just
label it Mark Cuban's in the house
ladies and gentlemen he's hanging out
with us and we're talking about life and
money and business things that he and I
like to talk about you're gonna have to
listen to us cuz he and I are both right
yeah don't ask my wife well we were
talking to going into the break about
just consumer debt and what it's doing
to people I read on your blog one time
and people people always send me well
anytime you say something about debt
people send it to me I got cubed six we
get what Cubans versa yeah so cut cut up
your credit cards if you use a credit
card you don't want to be rich yep I
like that line that's a good line my
favorite line I tell people all the time
if you use your credit cards you do not
want to be rich and people then they ask
me well where's the best place to invest
I said your best place to invest is to
pay off all your credit cards and burn
them because your credit card you know
what your return is right if you get off
you know you're paying fifteen twenty
percent interest in one way or the other
and if you pay that down you just earned
fifteen or twenty percent
it's that simple it's that simple and
folks I've told you a hundred times and
Forbes 400 400 wealthiest people in
North America when surveyed asked what's
the way to build wealth what's the
number one way to build wealth 75
percent of wealthy people not you're
broke brother-in-law with opinion but
wealthy people say get out of debt
and stay out of debt yep because it
gives you power over your largest wealth
building tool which is your income so
you got the Mark Cuban stamp of approval
on that right now that's good so one of
my favorite things just about watching
you with the Mavs or watching you on
Shark Tank or just watching you live
your life wide-open I mean you you don't
you have two speeds asleep and wide open
it's exactly right off and on I'm the
same way so I I'm working because I love
to work absolutely I love to kill things
and drag them home dad you know what I'm
so competitive I like to win that's
right and I get just accurate I go home
I like that I get frustrated with this
bunch who says that the opportunities
are over and we need somebody to help us
because we're all victim
and the economy is broken and if we
don't raise taxes or we don't do this or
we don't do that aside from the politics
of that there's just a hopelessness that
horatio alger is dead that they that the
American dream has become a nightmare
and that the corporation's have squeezed
all of the juice out of the economy and
the little man can't get ahead and it's
never said that way it's always say with
a wine the little man can get well you
know we know that's wrong I mean that's
the beauty of shark tank right that's
why I love to do the show because it
sends the message that the American
Dream is alive and well and all you have
to do is look at Susan from Iowa and
Johnny from you know Pittsburgh that are
coming in here with ideas that they
started in their kitchen or their
bedroom that they turned into companies
and they have the courage to come out
here and try to compete with us for for
an investment but even if they don't get
an investment they know that they have
what it takes to go out there and
succeed there are there everyday proof
that the American Dream is alive and
well and ideas are everywhere aren't
they oh yeah ideas are easy it's finding
people to do them and part of finding
somebody to do them is that person
actually has to have hope they have to
believe it works well of course I mean
what's good is an idea if you don't
believe in it and you have to believe in
it enough to actually take those first
steps because I think people when you
have an idea and you get some
confirmation of the idea then you start
looking for roadblocks because people
are afraid to do the work or they're
afraid to take those steps
I don't know anybody or I don't have the
capital you know businesses don't fail
for lack of capital they fail for lack
of brains and effort you know there
there are very few businesses that you
can't start with no money next to no
money if you have sweat equity sweat
equity is the best capital you could
ever have and you have an unlimited
supply and I say this too I say this to
our the Mavericks basketball players and
I say to everybody in business the one
thing in life that you can control is
your effort and if you're willing to put
in an effort to start the business and
you're willing to deal with the
challenges and the fact that you might
starve you might have to live like a
student you might have to go through a
lot of down times but if you're willing
to fight through those via your effort
and putting in you know using your brain
power then
anything is possible and there's no
reason it can't be you with the downturn
in the economy we just kind of come
through I was reading a report this
morning that the Fed is all worried that
the interest rate is going to have to
stay low perpetually because it's
languishing and it's more this negative
negative and negative negative negative
negative I just I with technology being
where it is I think it's the best time
in the history of man to start a
business or to be in business yeah you
kidding me you know it's funny because
there are so many things going on in the
economy right now we have this shared
economy which I don't think people take
into account right you can start funding
yourself and start a business by you
know renting out your couch on
couch-surf com right
by renting out a room an air B&B and use
that to raise money and then you know
going out there and to start a
technology business all you need is a
broadband account a phone sometime in an
effort and maybe a laptop if you really
want to get fancy and you can start any
technology business that you want I was
doing a business conference one of our
entree leadership things up in
Cincinnati a few months ago and sat down
the backstage dinner thing you know with
the VIPs or whatever and this kid
sitting next to me is 19 years old and
this up what is the little farm animal
thing they have with the kids a
Minecraft yeah he wrote
he's written like six apps for Minecraft
and he made like eight million dollars
like he read right yeah Christ kids are
downloading like a buck apiece eight
million of money it's ridiculous Angry
Bird - oh what the heck's the one-on-one
guy made so much money he freaked out
the oh I'm spacing the name of it um but
it's a little jumping thing um but in
any event you know the opportunities are
there there's a company called twitch
and all they did basically was stream
people playing video games and then
allow you also to save your video game
play and comment on it and allow others
to replay it so that kids who want to
really see how the best video game
players could watch it online now
they're getting a billion dollar offer
from from YouTube I mean just look you
know figuring out pain points there's so
many opportunities in this life you're
working on one that's really cool right
now with this texting right all about
the thing if you out cyberdust and what
happens is when you send a text right
now
spots ey BER dust2 words when you send a
text a minute you hit Send you lose
ownership of that text when you send it
it could be a friend it can be a
business associate whatever they can
save it they can forward it they can
post it and to me in this day and age
you want to shrink your digital
footprint you don't want to leave
anything for chance to chance in my
particular case I've gotten sued by the
government who went and looked at all my
messages and if I said this guy was blue
they said no you really meant this guy
was green and that you know really you
know propelled me to create cyberdust to
really take the effort to say I needed
to get complete control of anything that
I send in any type of messaging app and
forever is forever and you know
everybody keeps my text everybody I'm
sure it keeps your text right
but even like my 11 my 10 about to be 11
year old daughter she's going to send a
text someday or would have been able to
send a text someday to some little boy
that he's going to keep it and posted on
the Facebook that whatever whatever
replaces Facebook or posted on Twitter
and you know there's nothing she can do
about it and so I want to give her some
control over digital footprint we teach
our kids today you know be careful what
pictures you post on Facebook because he
can keep you from getting into college
keep you from getting a job
we haven't been teaching them be careful
what you text because they can be saved
they can be posted as well cyber dust
solves that problem by saying when you
send a cyber dust message to another
side with us user 30 seconds after they
opened the message it disappears forever
it is gone forever
it you can't go back and pull it from
the phone or device our drive you can't
pull it from our servers because it
never touches our servers hard drives
and so that shrinks your digital
footprint and I think that's important
now and it's going to become
increasingly important as we go forward
before we run out of time Mark Cuban is
living the dream you're saying no
question about it and Sam life is good
and it's not perfect nobody everybody
knows that everybody's got stuff to deal
with but talk to somebody out there
who's right now scared and they're not
living the dream
but they but they need to you know I
remember I was living six guys in a
3-bedroom apartment eating mushroom and
ketchup sandwiches
and I knew every morning that I woke up
even though I had nothing that I could
wake up with a smile on my face and look
forward to a day to every day because
every day there was an opportunity and
if you can find something whatever it is
that you love to do find something you
love to do and be great at it it may not
happen today it may not happen tomorrow
but if you keep on grinding anything is
possible mustard and ketchup sandwich it
was good I love it oh it's a wish
sandwich I wish I had some me oh brother
thank you for coming out you Dave I
really enjoyed it never to hang out with
you
Mark Cuban ladies and gentlemen oh man
that was fine
this is mine is the Dave Ramsey show
you